Ich möchte noch einmal
auf unseren Film zurückkommen,
den wir am letzten Freitag
veröffentlicht haben:
"Corona-Lockdown -
die Bewacher der Schweizer Grenze".
Auf YouTube lief er sehr gut, es gab
grosses Interesse, was uns freute.
Wir bekamen viele positive
und kritische Rückmeldungen,
aber auch viele Fragen.
Auf einige der Kommentare und Fragen
möchte ich eingehen.
Wir beginnen mit dem Titel
"Corona-Lockdown".
Es wurde mehrmals angemerkt,
dass der Film selbst
gar nicht wirklich Corona behandelte.
Das stimmt,
wir haben das transparent gemacht.
Der Hintergrund ist folgendermassen:
Im letzten Herbst begann ich an
dem Thema Grenzwächter zu arbeiten.
Es interessierte mich,
was diese in der heutigen Zeit
der offenen Grenzen machen.
Wie sind sie tätig, wie können sie
noch für Sicherheit sorgen?
Der Arbeitstitel des Films war:
"Die Beschützer der offenen Grenze".
Ich war eigentlich
fast fertig mit dem Film -
und genau in diesem Moment wurde
die Schliessung der Grenze verordnet.
Die vom Bundesrat
verordnete Grenzschliessung.
Wir wollten das Thema trotzdem
bringen, weil es topaktuell war.
Denn es sind genau diese Grenz-
wächter, die die Grenze schlossen.
Wir wollten einen aktuellen Teil
hinzufügen, drehten noch einmal.
Wir wollten aber doch
ein Bild davon zeigen,
wie die Grenzwächter/-innen
heute arbeiten.
Viele fragten nach dem Unterschied
zwischen Polizei und Grenzwache.
Ich habe einen Grenzwächter gefragt,
er sagte, oft sei es deckungsgleich.
Beide dürfen Kontrollen durchführen,
Auto und Waren kontrollieren.
Grenzwächter kümmern sich v.a.
um grenzüberschreitende Themen.
Sie kontrollieren Dokumente -
z.B. Pässe oder Visen.
Den Zoll natürlich und die Migration.
Die Polizei hat z.T. ...
Es gibt Dinge, bei denen nur
die Polizei zum Einsatz kommt.
Z.B. in der Kriminaltechnik -
also Mord - oder Verkehrsunfälle.
Das ist Sache der Polizei
und nicht der Grenzwache.
Und rein strukturell:
Die Grenzwache ist ein Teil
der eidg. Zollverwaltung.
Die Polizeieinheiten
sind v.a. kantonal geregelt,
auf Bundesebene
ist es ein Teil des EJPD.
Ja, dann gab es noch solche Fragen:
Hat es die Schweiz
zu lange locker genommen?
Hat man zu spät reagiert?
Da kann ich nicht viel dazu sagen,
das war kein Thema des Films.
Viele haben gefragt, ob auch
die Armee an der Grenze aktiv wird.
Momentan ist es so:
Es gab ja eine Mobilisierung.
Insgesamt 8'000 Soldaten -
es stehen noch nicht alle im Einsatz.
Momentan sind das
v.a. Sanitätskompanien.
Das sind Spitalsoldaten, die v.a.
in den Spitälern helfen werden.
Aber ich habe gehört,
dass es durchaus denkbar ist -
da laufen auch schon
erste Vorbereitungen -
dass Schweizer Soldaten auch bei der
Sicherung der Grenze helfen werden.
Soweit ich weiss,
wird das auch schon geübt,
aber das ist
noch nicht wirklich offiziell.
Was haben wir noch?
Jemand fragte mich,
was man machen soll,
wenn man bei der Grenzpolizei
arbeiten will.
Das kann man auf der Seite
der eidg. Zollverwaltung nachschauen,
soweit ich weiss,
sind sie froh um Bewerbungen.
Aber da müsst ihr
euch selbst informieren.
Das ist nicht unbedingt meine Sache.
Es wurde gefragt, wieso keine
Schutzmasken getragen werden.
Als ich nachfragte,
gab es ein gewisses Räuspern.
Das ist also eine heikle Frage.
Jene, die wollen,
können Masken tragen.
Aber es sei bei der Arbeit
auch nicht ganz einfach.
Sie haben aber die Weisung,
2 m Abstand zu halten.
Wenn die Zollbeamten oder die Grenz-
wächter z.B. Autos kontrollieren,
müssen sie 2 m Abstand halten.
Eine Frage,
die mir jetzt erst einfällt:
Wie machen sie es mit dem Abtasten?
Wir haben im Film gesehen,
dass sie Verdächtige z.T. abtasten.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall
Handschuhe an.
Aber es fragt sich,
wie gefährlich das sein könnte.
Es gab noch Fragen zu meiner Vergan-
genheit als Russland-Korrespondent.
Jemand fragte,
was mein gefährlichster Moment
mit russischen Grenzbeamten war.
Wirklich gefährlich
wurde es eigentlich nie.
Aber eine interessante Geschichte
passierte während des
Ukraine-Russland-Konflikts.
Da gab es keine direkten Flüge mehr
von Moskau nach Kiew.
Darum nutzte ich oft den Nachtzug,
in beide Richtungen.
Wenn man über die Grenze fuhr,
gab es natürlich auch Kontrollen.
Dann kamen die Beamten und meinten:
"Schweizer und auch noch Journalist".
Es gab sofort einen Aufruhr,
es wurde gefunkt:
"Hallo, wir haben einen Journalisten,
einen Ausländer, Schweizer."
Dann kam für gewöhnlich der Leiter
des Grenzgeheimdienstes vorbei
und stellte einige Fragen - wohin
man gehe, was man gedreht habe usw.
Das war nicht sehr angenehm.
Denn plötzlich wusste der ganze
Wagen, dass ich in diesem Zug sitze.
Aber das gehörte dazu.
Ähm.
Ich schaue noch ein wenig weiter.
Oder ich mache mal eine Pause.
Jemand schaute aus Köln zu
und hatte folgende Frage:
Er habe seine Freundin in der
Schweiz, wie kann er diese besuchen?
Da kann ich leider nicht helfen.
Ich kann nur mitfühlen - ich hoffe,
das ändert sich bald einmal.
Aber in der Verordnung des Bundesrats
steht sehr detailliert,
wer noch in die Schweiz darf.
In der Regel Schweizer oder Personen
mit einer Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
oder Personen, die ein
Grenzgängerdokument besitzen.
Diese können auch kommen,
sonst wird es ziemlich schwierig.
Es gibt Ausnahmen,
z.B. bei Beerdigungen.
Oder bei Härtefällen.
Aber ob eine normale Beziehung
Teil davon ist, weiss ich nicht.
Es gab
eine weitere interessante Frage.
Es gibt ja eigentlich auf beiden Se-
iten der Grenze einen Einreisestopp.
Im Falle unseres Films in Deutschland
und der Schweiz.
Oder in Österreich oder Italien
Wenn also die deutschen Grenzbehörden
jemanden kontrollieren,
kontrollieren die Schweizer
Behörden dann auch noch einmal
oder vertraut man sich
da gegenseitig?
Es ist so: Jedes Land
kontrolliert die Einreise.
Die Deutschen kontrollieren nicht,
wer ausreist
und die Schweizer kontrollieren
nicht, wer ausreist.
Es wird jeweils kontrolliert,
wer einreist.
Insofern gibt es
schon eine Zusammenarbeit,
aber jedes Land kontrolliert selbst,
welche Leute einreisen dürfen.
Eine weitere Frage war,
wie die Leute reagieren.
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Es gab bis jetzt
wohl über 10'000 Abweisungen.
Zu Beginn sorgte das
für Ärger und Unverständnis.
Sie beklagten sich auch,
das sah man im Film,
dass die vorhandenen Absperrungen
umfahren werden.
Oder dass sie
immer wieder weggeräumt wurden.
Soweit ich weiss, sind im Grenzgebiet
nach wie vor Helikopter unterwegs,
die so etwas unterbinden sollen.
Es ist natürlich nachvollziehbar.
Gerade Grenzgänger,
die jeden Tag zur Arbeit kommen,
die oft ganz wichtige Arbeit ausüben,
in Spitälern, am Flughafen usw.,
müssen für den Arbeitsweg jetzt
z.T. grosse Umwege auf sich nehmen.
Weil die kleinen Grenzübergänge
jetzt geschlossen sind.
Das hat man ja
auf ein paar wenige konzentriert.
Z.T. hat man darum 5-10 km Umweg.
Und das sorgt z.T. für Ärger.
Was auch noch interessant ist:
Es gibt anscheinend nicht nur in den
Städten, sondern auch an den Grenzen
gewisse Spannungen zwischen Auto-
und Velofahrern sowie Fussgängern.
Z.T. beklagte man sich,
dass Fussgänger und Velofahrer
einfacher über die Grenze kommen.
Dazu kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Das Verbot gilt eigentlich für alle.
Aber die Grenzen sind so lang
und wir haben ja - Gott sei Dank -
weder Grenzmauern noch Grenzzäune.
Und ... Ja, da kann ich sonst
nicht viel dazu sagen.
Eine andere Frage: Oft sah man,
dass man das schon vor zwei
oder drei Wochen hätte tun sollen.
Da wird man am Schluss hoffentlich
eine Bilanz ziehen.
Ich selbst kann da
nicht viel dazu sagen.
Das ist eine politische Frage.
Man muss dazu noch sagen,
dass sich die Grenzschützer
nie politisch äussern wollten.
Es war von Anfang an vereinbart, dass
es keine politischen Kommentare gibt.
Z.B. ob es gut oder schlecht ist,
die Grenze zu schliessen.
In der Regel war immer jemand
vom Mediendienst dabei,
der ein Auge darauf hatte.
Wir haben frei gearbeitet, aber
politische Fragen waren ein Tabu.
Jemand wirft mir vor, dass das
"ideologische Anspielungen
für eine grenzenlose und
globalisierte Multikultiwelt" waren.
Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Es geht wohl um die Szene, in der ich
die Grenzwache in Brig fragte,
ob man nicht manchmal das Gefühl hat,
man kann die Leute durchlassen,
auch wenn mit den Papieren
nicht alles stimmt.
Mir war schon klar,
dass man das eigentlich nicht darf.
Aber bei solchen Fragen
geht es ja auch darum,
die Leute aus der Reserve zu locken -
und die Frage ist interessant.
Gerade bei der Migration,
bei Familien mit Kindern,
die in der Schweiz
kein Asyl beantragen wollen,
sondern einfach
durchs Land reisen wollen.
Und man diese nicht durchlässt.
Oder wie einmal im Film:
Ein einfacher Arbeiter,
dessen Schengen-Aufent-
haltsbewilligung abgelaufen ist.
Da kommt schon die Frage auf,
ob man als Grenzwächter nicht
manchmal gerne sagen würde:
"Ja, komm durch,
da drücken wir ein Auge zu."
Aber unter dem Strich
müssen wir wahrscheinlich froh sein,
dass wir Personal haben, das die
Gesetze anwendet und durchzieht.
Aber es ist
eigentlich nicht von mir aus ...
Das war eigentlich keine ideologische
Anspielung von meiner Seite,
sondern eine berechtigte Frage.
Ich glaube, das wär's.
Das war's im Grossen und Ganzen.
Sie können nach wie vor
Fragen stellen.
Wir beantworten sie gerne.
Wenn Sie das noch nicht getan haben,
abonnieren Sie uns doch:
Auf dem Kanal srf.ch/dok. Es gibt
immer ganz spannende Filme hier.
Sehr aktuelle zum Thema Corona, aber
auch sonstige Hintergrundberichte.
Das ist spannend - ich hoffe, wir
sehen uns wieder auf diesem Kanal.